was ist da los seit jahrzehnten wird
immer wieder über die kalte fusion
spekulieren also das was in riesigen
versuchsreaktoren unter riesigem druck
und unglaublichen temperaturen
irgendwann mal erreicht werden soll
und das soll bei zimmertemperatur
gelingen ein forschungsteam der nasa hat
jetzt eine fusions methode realisiert
die ganz ohne plasma und starke
magnetfelder auskommt was ist da los
also gibt's die kalte fusion liegt uns
im blut jedes dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen kernfusion können einzig und
allein unter extrem hohen temperaturen
und drücken erfolgen so der stand der
dinge bis jetzt doch ein forschungsteam
der nasa hat spannende ergebnisse
veröffentlicht dazu die nasa forscherin
theresa mio
die an der aktuellen studie beteiligt
war fachleute sind an fusionstechnik
interessiert weil diese enorme mengen an
energie erzeugen könnten ohne
langanhaltende radioaktive neben
produkte zu erzeugen
die entwicklung und der betrieb
herkömmlicher fusionsreaktoren ist
jedoch super kompliziert da sie auf
extrem hohe temperaturen angewiesen sind
um die starke elektrostatische abstoßung
zwischen positiv geladenen kernen zu
überwinden
zusammen mit ihren kolleginnen und
kollegen ließ die reserven deuterium
kerne miteinander verschmelzen es kam zu
einer fusion und das bei
zimmertemperatur liegt das aktuelle nasa
experiment und sie jetzt die hoffnung
zurück dass kernfusion doch noch in die
energiequelle für unsere zukunft werden
könnte und dass schon bald und mit viel
geringerem aufwand als bisher gedacht
bei manch einem kommen bei dieser
meldung vielleicht erinnerungen an die
methode der kalten fusion noch zwei
us-forscher hatten vor 31 jahren 1989
behauptet dass ihnen mit hilfe einer
sehr einfachen versuchsanordnung die
verschmelzung von atomkernen bei
raumtemperatur gelungen sei medien
berichteten damals von einer riesigen
sensation denn um atomkerne zu
verschmelzen sind normalerweise eben
hohe temperaturen und drücke notwendig
ebenso wie sie im innern
von sternen vorherrschen da sehen die
temperatur niedriger und der druck höher
hier auf der erde müssen dafür höhere
temperaturen erreicht werden rund 100
millionen grad dann kann hier auf der
erde
nach jetzigem stand die kernfusion
erreicht werden die natürlichen
fusionskraftwerke des kosmos sind die
sterne und die abläufe in deren inneren
versuchen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler schon seit jahren auf
der erde nachzuahmen die riesige
herausforderung dabei um die kerne von
elementen wie wasserstoff oder helium
dazu zu bringen zu verschmelzen muss
deren extrem starke gegenseitige
abstoßung überwunden werden
doch dann kann auch solch einer
verschmelzung eine gigantische menge an
energie entzogen werden denn achtung an
funktionieren da für sie uns reaktor
könnte durch ein gramm der brennstoffe
so viel energie liefern wie sie bei der
verbrennung von elf tonnen kohle
entsteht mögliche brennstoffe werden
beispielsweise die wasserstoff isotope
tritium und deuterium chemisch gesehen
passiert bei einer kern versuchen das
folgende die atomkerne vom wasserstoff
verschmelzen unter sehr hohem druck und
bei sehr hoher temperatur miteinander im
gegensatz zur kernspaltung bilden
vereinfacht gesagt zwei leichte atome
ein schweres die gesamtmasse des neuen
atoms ist geringer als die der beiden
einzelnen das was fehlt ist die
entstandene energie doch es gibt noch
einige herausforderungen die fachleute
weltweit den schlaf rauben wie kann man
es schaffen mehr energie aus dem
fusionsprozess herauszuholen als man
hinein steckt wie und wann wird es
forschungsteams gelingen in einem
fusionskraftwerk ein plasma strom
dauerhaft denn das ist die große
herausforderung am brennen zu halten und
welches material lässt sich finden das
den krassen belastungen an der innenwand
des plasma gefäßes standhält
der technische aufwand ist also extrem
doch die fusion hat dafür enorm viele
vorteile sie geht als sauberer und auch
als effizienter als die atom spannung
trotz jahrelanger und wirklich
intensiver forschung aber gibt es bisher
noch keinen fusionsreaktor der zur
stromerzeugung geeignet ist und auch
immer über dem wir ja berichtet haben in
franck
das ist ein forschungsreaktor weil wir
dem man den dauerhaften brand zwar
erreichen möchte der aber keine energie
liefern wird zurück zum jahr 1989 und
der kalten version martin fleischmann
und stanley pons wollten also die
verschmelzung von atomkernen mit hilfe
eines wirklich simplen versuchsaufbaus
erreicht haben dazu schrieben sie damals
es scheint so als wäre es möglich eine
fortlaufende fusionsreaktion mit einer
relativ billigen vorrichtung zu
realisieren konkret hatten die beiden
forscher soll terium also schweren
wasserstoff in einen stab aus palladium
geleitet genau dort waren die dolly um
kerner nach angaben der wissenschaftler
zu helium verschmolzen und energie wurde
frei und zwar ganz ohne hohe
temperaturen und extremen drücke nach
angaben des forschungsteams sei es
während der elektrolyse an der
oberfläche des palladiums zur
verschmelzung der wasserstoff isotope
deuterium und tritium und profi
umgekommen eine registrierte überschuss
wärmeproduktion sei der eindeutige
nachweis dafür dass sich daraus
tatsächlich energie gewinnen lassen
können
eine nukleare fusion also auf
elektrochemischen weg und das bei
zimmertemperatur hatten pons und
verspannt ist also tatsächlich geschafft
das sonnenfeuer auf der erde zu zünden
würde so der weg frei zu einer neuen
form der energiegewinnung dabei hatten
fachleute weltweit schon seit vielen
jahren versucht die kernfusion wie sie
auch in der sonne abläuft auf der erde
nachzuahmen
doch die welt hatte sich damals zu früh
gefreut denn es gelang einfach niemandem
das experiment von pons und fleischmarkt
zu reproduzieren
dazu der us-physiker sagte hassan ii
theoretiker haben bewiesen dass die
behauptung von fleischmann und ponce ein
ding der unmöglichkeit war und
experimentalphysiker konnten den effekt
schlicht nicht reproduzieren und zwar
bis heute nicht auch pommes und
fleischmann selbst konnten ihre
ergebnisse nicht vor zeugen wiederholen
in anderen experimenten konnten außerdem
fehler bei fleischmann und ponce
versuchsaufbau nachgewiesen werden
eine kommission des us
energieministeriums hatte dann ende des
jahres 1989 eine entscheidung getroffen
demnach seien zitat die gegenwärtigen
hinweise auf die entdeckung eines
kern physikalischen prozesse genannt
kalte fusion nicht überzeugen das
schreckte forschende zunächst erst
einmal davon ab sich weiter an diesem
thema zu widmen
dennoch ist das wissenschaftliche
interesse an der kalten fusion immer
noch nicht ganz erloschen
denn es wäre ja auch einfach viel zu
schön um wahr zu sein und so geht es
nicht nur im film und büchern um dieses
thema sondern auch einige
forschergruppen beschäftigen sich wieder
damit oft passiert das jetzt aber unter
der bezeichnung ler das ist die
abkürzung für low energy nuclear
reactions also ema anders als der
begriff der kalten fusion ist die
bezeichnung lg n a in der fachwelt
keineswegs einfach nur verrufen am glenn
research center in den usa wollen die
fachleute um theresa wenn also jetzt
eine fusions methode entwickelt haben
die technisch gesehen relativ simpel
scheint denn die neu entwickelte methode
soll sowohl ohne starke magnetfelder als
auch ohne plasma auskommen laut der neu
veröffentlichten studie benötigt das
forschungsteam um boost dein netz und
theresa wenn du lediglich einen
elektronenbeschleuniger wasserstoff und
metall und die einrichtung des glenn
research sind das ist tatsächlich
ziemlich renommiert an diesem nasa
forschungsinstitut wird schon seit
mehreren jahrzehnten an neuen
technologien für die luft und raumfahrt
getüftelt tatorte haben wir
beispielsweise einen ionen antrieb
entwickelt der heutzutage bei vielen
kommerziellen kommunikationssatelliten
standardmäßig eingebaut wird und auch
die neuen ergebnisse in sachen fusions
methoden könnten in diesem zusammenhang
ganz neue möglichkeiten mit sich bringen
und vergleiche mit der kalten fusion aus
den 80er jahren lässt das forschungsteam
nicht zu das forschungsteam schreibt was
wir getan haben war keine kalte fusion
die fachleute aus den usa bestehen
darauf dass es sich bei ihrem verfahren
um eine spezielle form der heißen fusion
handelt doch bei dem von ihnen
entwickelten verfahren sei der
technische aufwand deutlich kleiner als
bei den versuchsreaktoren die bislang
entwickelt wurden die rede ist von einer
so genannten la tiscon für den füßen was
in etwa so viel meint wie gitta
begrenzungs fusion was dabei im
einzelnen passiert ist ist wirklich
nicht ohne glas aber dass dabei das
metall
bio mit deuterium atomen angereichert
wird das passiert unter hohem druck so
wurden die proben von erbium und titan
also mit terium gas einem wasserstoff
isotope mit einem proton und einem
neutron bepackt dazu sagt die forscherin
theresa banjo während des ladevorgangs
beginnt das metallgitter auseinander zu
brechen um das kriterium gas halten zu
können
das ergebnis ist dann wie ein pulver die
herausforderung für das forschungsteam
bestand dann darin die sogenannte
colomba ehre zu überwinden fachleute
meinen damit die energie barriere im
kern potenzial die ein positiv geladenes
teilchen überwinden muss um in den
atomkernen einzudringen oder aus ihm
heraus zu kommen in diesem fall kann man
das kurz auch als die gegenseitige
elektrostatische abstoßung zwischen den
positiv geladenen deuterium kern
bezeichnet um also diese colomba rhi
ehre zu überwinden wurde im ersten
schritt energiereiche gamma strahlung
erzeugt dazu wurde wolfram mit
elektronen beschossen
die entstandene gammastrahlung wurde auf
die titan oder erbium probe gelenk die
ja im experiment zuvor mit helium
beladen worden war sobald ein deutscher
rohn von einem photon getroffen wurde
sehr viel dieses und zwar in ein
neutronen und ein energiereiches proton
das neutron beschleunigte weiterhin ein
anderes deutschen sobald es mit diesem
zusammen traf und es geht noch weiter
das somit beschleunigte deutsche
rundfunk zitiert mit einem weiteren
deutscher und dabei frei werden entweder
ein neutron oder ein helium 3 oder ein
proton und tritium und damit kommen wir
auch schon zum entscheidenden punkt denn
am ende dieses prozesses bewegt sich
also eindeutig und mit sehr hoher
energie es kann die cola bier überwinden
und so kommt es dass es mit einem
anderen deutschen im gitter verschmilzt
das metallgitter sei entscheidend damit
eine fusion stattfinden kann so das
forschungsteam in der neu
veröffentlichten studie
denn so wird quasi garantiert dass die
klopp barriere auf jeden fall überwunden
werden kann und die fusion stattfinden
kann dazu schreiben die nasa forschenden
die elektronen im gitter bilden eine
abschirmung um das stationäre deutsche
und die negative ladung der elektronen
schützt das energie
reichen leute und vor den abstoßenden
effekten der positiven leitung des ziels
bis die kerne nah genug an einander
geraten heißt also dass die elektronen
quasi wie eine art schutzschirm
formieren doch neben dieser deutsche
wohnen deutschen fusion macht das
forschungsteam noch eine weitere
spannende entdeckung die rede ist von
den sogenannten oppenheimer philipp
stripping reaktionen denn nicht immer
fusioniert das energetische deutschen
mit einem anderen deuten manchmal stieß
es auch gegen eines der metallatome das
geht das so entstand dann entweder ein
isotop und in manchen fällen wurde das
atom in ein neues element umgewandelt in
der fachsprache ist von einer so
genannten strip reaktion die rede und
auch hier wurde nutzbare energie erzeugt
ebenso wie also bei der fusionsreaktion
denn wenn die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nach dem experiment die
proben berührt hatten waren diese waren
und diese wärme stammt demnach nicht nur
von den energiereichen photonen wodurch
der prozess überhaupt erst in gang
gesetzt wurde sondern auch zu einem
anderen teil aus der fusionsreaktion
dazu heißt es diese fusions methode
startet zwar bei niedrigen temperaturen
und drücken aber dort wo die
eigentlichen deutschen deutschen fusion
stattfindet wird es sehr heiß die nasa
vorständen sind optimistisch dass ihre
ergebnisse schon bald auch in der praxis
genutzt werden könnten vor allem sehen
sie ihre fusionsreaktion als mögliche
energiequelle für raumfahrzeuge die dort
eingesetzt werden wo keine
sonnenkollektoren möglich sind doch die
fachleute räumen auch ein dass ihr
prozess dafür noch deutlich effizienter
ablaufen muss erst dann könnte man einen
gedanken daran verschwenden dass solch
ein verfahren auch auf der erde energie
liefern kann also zum einen eine
wahnsinns nachricht also das fusion je
zu solchen bedingungen stattfinden
könnte das hat keiner für möglich
gehalten und zum ersten mal ist damit
hier auf der erde eine fusion unter
weitaus weniger extremen bedingungen als
in einem fusionsreaktor gelungen aber
zum anderen wie auch in den bisherigen
fusionsreaktoren kann so keine energie
gewonnen werden trotzdem ein extrem
spannender ansatz der uns in der zukunft
sicher noch oft beschäftigen
apropos zukunft um die geht es in meinem
neuen buch per aufzug in den weltraum
wer also einen wissenschaftlichen blick
in die zukunft werfen möchte der sollte
dieses buch lesen der link ist hier und
das buch gibt es natürlich in jeder
guten buchhandlung bis dann bleibt dran